We need to know that
the things we're producing
are safe, are actually
giving us the effect
that we are intending
to create, as well
as not causing any harm.
I think there's a
lot of hope and promise
to having standardized tools
that are used across pharma.
The open source
mindset allows you to ask
all kinds of possibilities.
You can go right back
and, if you're not sure
if something's right, you
can go and explore it.
I think there's a lot
of value in open source,
because that pipeline,
although somewhat
idiosyncratic and unique across
different pharma companies,
at the end of the
day is standardized.
You can get people who have
both industry experience,
they understand what it is
to build an atom data set.
They understand that
process, and so they
have the right skills.
They're just a lot
more transferable.
So I use Posit packages almost
every day when I'm working,
and it makes it
just incredibly easy
to build a package that is
quality, that it's tested.
As a statistician
for instance,
being able to have an
open source package that's
already available greatly
increases how quickly
you can try that method out.
Our submission
process is still
based around, essentially,
paper submissions.
We've made the paper into PDFs,
but it's pretty much the same
as it was 20 or 30 years ago.
By submitting to regulators
with open source software,
they can immediately
access that same code.
They can run it on
their own machines,
and verify that they are getting
the same results that we are.
We give them a
lot of code in order
to show, like, this is
all of the things we did.
And when it's in an R
package, it's lovely.
It's easy, that's portable.
It's open source, we don't
even have to port it anywhere.
It's already out there.
I think the possibility
now with open source,
and particularly
something like R,
where you've got
a tool like Shiny,
is you can start to deliver that
submission in a different way.
I think we'll be sharing
the data directly
with the regulators in future.
We'll be worried less
about how we format that
and get it to look really
nice on a piece of paper.
And I hope that we'll
be able to deliver
these kind of interactive apps
to regulators in the future.